en matière de climat les états unis de
joe biden entend bien donner le la après
avoir fait revenir son pays dans le
cadre de l'accord de paris dès le début
de son mandat
le locataire de la maison blanche qui
s'est donné pour objectif d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici à 2050
réunis autour d'une table virtuelle 40
dirigeants mondiaux car washington
combien se pose est désormais en leader
dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a martelé le
chef de la diplomatie américaine cette
semaine
si l'amérique ne mène pas le monde dans
la gestion de la crise climatique
il ne restera plus grand chose de notre
planète
précisons tout de même que les états
unis sont le deuxième plus gros
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre avec
6,6 gigatonnes en équivalent co2 en 2019
selon le programme des nations unies
pour l'environnement
la chine elle rafle la première place
avec 14 gigatonnes en 2019
shirin pin sera d'ailleurs parmi les
invités samedi malgré des divergences
sur de nombreux dossiers les deux pays
se sont entendus pour coopérer sur le
terrain du changement climatique selon
un communiqué conjoint signé par john
kerry l'émissaire américain pour le
climat et son homologue chinois shi
danois
les états unis et la chine s'engage à
coopérer entre eux et avec d'autres pays
pour affronter la crise climatique qui
doit être traité avec le sérieux et
l'urgence qu'elle exige autres invités
vladimir poutine le président russe qui
devrait présenter la proche du pays
je cite dans le contexte de
l'établissement d'une large coopération
internationale pour lutter contre le
changement climatique
et puis il y a bien sûr les pays de
l'union européenne les 27 qui se sont
entendus in extremis à la veille de ce
sommet sur une réduction nette d'au
moins 55% de leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici à 2030
c'est un moment historique pour l'ue eux
l'accord renforce notre position dans le
monde comme un leader du combat contre
la crise climatique
de son côté washington doit dévoiler ce
jeudi sont propres objectifs climatiques
révisé pour 2030
reste à savoir si au delà des grandes
promesses des pays
signataire de l'accord de paris les
objectifs seront atteignables
nous nous dirigeons tout droit vers une
catastrophe climatique alerté antonio
goûter res le secrétaire général de
l'onu en février dernier car depuis la
première coop en 1995 les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont loin d'avoir
diminué chez le 20 avril dernier
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie a
indiqué qu'elle s'attendait à une
augmentation de ses émissions d'un 1,5
milliard de tonnes de co2 en 2021 soit
près de 5 % de plus par rapport à 2019
des résultats qui pose question à
quelques mois de la 26ème coop prévu à
glace qu au royaume uni en novembre
prochain